[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview of first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
Daily Mirror Economist Susie Boniface
and the editor of the Jewish Chronicle
Jake Wallace Simons they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now
the telegraph leads with the death of
six children from strep a infections
the mail reports that experts believe
youngsters immunity to strepi could be
compromised because of time spent away
from their peers during covert lockdowns
the mirror focuses on The Human Side of
the outbreak picturing one of the
victims four-year-old Muhammad Ibrahim
Ali
a poll in the eye suggests one in seven
people who voted to leave the EU would
Now cast their ballot to remain instead
the times understands a strike action by
members of the Royal College of Nursing
later this month could affect AMD
departments and cancer Awards
the guardian claimed an exclusive where
the report that up to half a million
vulnerable families are missing out on
help with their energy bills this winter
because vouchers for prepayment meters
are being lost delayed or unclaimed
the express hears that the king wants to
be supportive of Prince Harry but could
reach a point of no return
the financial times here's that Russia
has gathered a fleet of more than 100
Antiquated oil tankers in an effort to
evade the many Western sanctions imposed
on them
the star has the most important story
meat eaters will hear today Christmas
Pig in blankets are apparently under
threat because of the increasing price
of chipolatas
and the sun has a boxer Tyson Fury
throwing his heavyweight behind the
England squad before their World Cup
match on Sunday and his own fight
against Derek chisora tomorrow night
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Suzy Boniface and Jake Wallace Simons
welcome to you both let us start with
the times and well the strikes are very
much um on people's minds at the moment
and this headline talking particularly
about the nurses and the fact that they
could walk out on cancer Awards and a e
Wards during the Christmas period Susie
so they are not promising that you know
chemotherapy and and some other things
are going to be absolutely protected but
uh you know the general Staffing levels
are going to go down to what you might
expect to see around Christmas time
um there's some concern about whether or
not radiotherapy or surgery would go
ahead on strike days
um and obviously if you go to a e and
your life is in danger if you've just
had a heart attack or something like
that a nurse is going to treat you don't
think you need to be too worried about
that but if you go to a e and you've got
a broken arm which you can easily
survive and it's not going to
immediately kill you
then the nurses aren't going to leave
the picket line for that one which will
mean that you could be in some pain you
could um you know be in a longer queue
to be dealt with by those staff who are
going to be providing the skeleton
service if you like
um and what's really interesting is that
despite the fact that all sounds really
drastic and really horrible and all of
us are going to be telling our families
over the next few weeks and months
please don't jump up and down on the
stairs small child this is not the time
that we want to go to hospital and
telling our parents just to be careful
and all the rest of it and to just
please don't go to hospital in the next
couple of months there is actually a
massive support for the nurses and the
strike action that is being taken and
the ballots that are coming up for
professions like Hospital Porters and
cleaners and the technicians and the
pharmacists who all work in hospitals 65
are supporting strike action by nurses
it says here we have to wait and see of
course whether that stays as solid as
support as the strikes wear on but it
does seem to be that generally speaking
you know this isn't quite like the the
strikes that I can remember as a as a
child
um which was sort of ideological against
thatcherism these are strikes that
people can understand no matter what
their Walk of Life is that those on
strike really need more pay to you know
to to put food in their on their bellies
and food on the table yes and Jake
that's uh you got polling for the Times
suggests that there is significant uh
public Sympathy for the strikes with 65
supporting the action by nurses but do
you think that support will continue
when people might be directly affected
by the strike
I think it's a it's a really really
difficult
um subject I mean strikes are difficult
to debate anyway let alone when we're
talking about nurses who amongst
Frontline workers are really very much
at the sharpest end
um they're you're right there is 65
support by the public for nurses because
everybody feels a lot of sympathy for
nurses don't get paid very much they
work super hard during the pandemic were
heroic during those years
um and are the great sort of unsung
heroes in general of the NHS but this
action I think will threaten to begin to
erode the public support once it begins
to take effect because nurses earn on
average about 37 000 pounds the average
full-time wage in the UK is 33 000
pounds so it's slightly above average
I'm not saying don't deserve it for a
moment what they're negotiating for is
almost a 20 rise which I think most
people will see as being a very large
demand and if people begin to go to a e
as Susie said and have a broken arm or
something and have it not treat because
of strikes a broken arm's not funny it's
it's very very painful and and can be
dangerous as well if not treated
properly and if you know mistakes begin
to be made because of strikes and
serious complications arise perhaps even
deaths or injuries
um I think serious questions will begin
to be asked by the public and that
support will begin to fall back
meanwhile we read in the telegraph the
um terrible case of the the six children
that have died as a result of
Contracting strep a
um there is another child that is a
critical in in hospital I mean this will
really play on people's mind considering
our previous story that we've been
talking about but parents now being told
to be on the alert and look out for
symptoms Susie
yeah now look I've had a I've got a
small child she's had scarlet fever
before now which is caused by strep a
um she had the best of care in the NHS
and I'm sure if any child suffers
serious complications they're going to
have the best that the NHS can do for
them as well and it does only affect
very few numbers of people I can barely
stand to even look at this story and
think about the poor families and the
children that have died
um
it's
unfortunate well it's not unfortunate
it's just one of the most horrible
things about this is that strepe often
tends to get children who are three four
five years old who are just starting out
in life and of course we need to bear in
mind that for for children that age half
their lives probably has been spent not
socializing as much with other people as
they normally would have done and that
will have increased their chances
perhaps of of not having very much
resistance to strep when it comes along
and therefore having the chances of a
more serious um reaction to it when it
does become invasive as it has done in
some of these cases so it is one of the
consequences perhaps of of the pandemic
and the care we all took of each other
um and I'm sure the NHS will be taking
the right care of those children that
are suffering and I'm I'm sorry I was
barely even able to watch Ashley's
Josh's report earlier on about the
little girl
um yeah up north just it's just too
difficult to watch isn't it no it is it
is extremely distressing
um but but as you say scientists are
saying that decision to close schools in
the and keep children apart during the
lockdown that's left a wider pool of
youngsters without immunity to to the
bacteria so it seems as if this probably
is a direct result of um of lockdowns
Jake
that's right I mean it you know for
those of us who felt uncomfortable at
the time when lockdowns were announced
and then throughout it's more evidence
it seems that suggesting that that cost
benefit analysis wasn't properly made
and we rushed into lockdown
um uh with a bit too much enthusiasm and
perhaps you know prolonged it a little
bit too much as well I mean look nobody
could have foreseen this I'm not saying
that for a moment but there was a sense
at the time sunak has said that since
um that the government didn't do a
proper cost benefits analysis uh and the
effects of having it locked down for
such a long time are so far-reaching and
are costing lives to this day you know
not just strep a uh deaths but also in
terms of the backlogged NHS backlog
um you know cancer deaths you know
excess deaths are high because of the
Fallout of lockdown at the moment and
this is just another Grim reminder that
lockdown does have very very
far-reaching consequences indeed indeed
let does have a quick look kirsty's we
just got time to have a look at the
express Sergey Javed is uh quitting at
the next election
the most part high profile Tory to bail
at this stage
um and it's because there's a deadline
of Monday for them to decide whether or
not they're standing for the next
election and that's partly because the
party wants to have a couple of years
ahead of the next election to prepare
and get new candidates ready rather than
rush them in but it adds to sort of a
general sense of Decay and the ruling
party if they just start having all
these people announcing two years in
advance games you know what this is
going nowhere I'm out it's not a good
look for the conservative party at all
it wouldn't be for any party that was
doing this sort of thing and I think to
be honest as well I mean I can I have
some sympathy for people who who fairly
certain they're going to be losing their
jobs in a couple of years time okay but
it's still a couple of years away and
it's a pretty well paid job
um and I I'm very uncomfortable about
the idea of MP spending the next two
years looking for the next one while not
really doing this one properly I'm extra
uncomfortable about people like such a
Javin his position saying well I you
know I support the government fully but
I want nothing to do with it they
plainly don't have the um courage of
their convictions there are things this
government are doing which they believe
are not going to get them you know
electable enough to win another election
so therefore why are you supporting the
government doing it why are you going to
spend the next two years voting with the
whip backing the government up when you
know that these things are going to be
far too painful to get reelected and
it's what public don't want
his decision to leave but we read in
some of the other papers that he is
already eyeing up other jobs in uh in
finance and the city thank you both for
the moment we are going to take a break
coming up is the king running out of
patience with Prince Harry the express
building so we'll discuss that and more
next
[Music]
thank you welcome back you're watching
the Press preview store with me Susie
Boniface and Jake Wallace Simons are
there
um let us have a look at the express and
um according to the paper the king is
running out of patience with Prince
Harry Susie
well this has been said a few times
before it also says further inside that
he would forgive Harry just about
anything
um I think what we've got here really is
the fact that
um the media need to want to keep
talking about Megan and Harry and the
the Royal race Rao because especially
that sells papers is the kind of thing
that everyone is talking about and has
an opinion on
um interestingly if you look if I look
on my Twitter everyone's sort of pro
Megan if I look at my Facebook
everyone's very anti the the poor lady
who is actually sort of had a go at by
Lady Susan Hussey allegedly
um and and it kind of has to sort of
rumble on I think in a way but it's also
not really been disproved or or fixed or
resolved um it says here that uh that
the palace has now reached out to ngozi
falani the lady who was sort of targeted
in this where are you from debacle being
asked eight times something which I
wouldn't be asked once and if I was last
I'd only have to answer it once I
wouldn't have to say it three or four
times
so which is obviously makes it racist
um and it's just that you know they've
got to keep on going on with this they
have reached out to her now but it
hasn't really been resolved and
meanwhile the the attention the
criticism has moved on to Megan who has
never said anything like this but
somehow we've got we've got a lady of
color who's been targeted in Harris in a
way that's quite unacceptable in
Buckingham Palace but the criticism is
about another lady of color who pointed
out to the Palace some time ago that
this sort of thing was likely and quite
bad and somehow it's criticism of Megan
that we're getting I don't understand
how we've got to that point it's it's a
mystery but the express is focusing on
the relationship with with Harry and the
King though isn't it Jake
that's writing based on Royal sources
the uh the express is suggesting that
Charles is saying that he will always
keep his door open to Harry but at the
same time sort of contradicting himself
by saying that there is a red line if he
crosses that then um there'll be
consequences and what that red line
might be uh might be that
um if he talks in his forthcoming books
spare which is coming out in in January
this uh you know 400 page incendiary
volume of criticism
um uh of the royal family if he includes
too much criticism of Camilla uh and his
father in The Narrative of his parents
divorce this Royal Source suggests that
that might be an enough is enough moment
for Prince for King Charles uh who then
may take the move made the move of
stripping the sussexes of their title
entirely and casting the Madrid yeah
there's also the uh the Netflix
um airing to come come about as well
isn't it just very quickly and there may
be a problem if you're a meat eater over
Christmas what is the star warning us
off Susie
there's an increase in the cost of
chipolatas fundamentally that's what we
come down to I'm not quite sure what the
headline uh is based on but I think it's
a massive fail they didn't get Peter
Andre in there somewhere but
fundamentally it means that for many
people the cost of Christmas dinner
which is already quite high of course is
going to be uh significantly more if
you're one of those people who likes
eating a miniature sausage wrapped in
bacon while you're doing it right thank
you you summed that up very well I won't
um go into the pizza Andre reference
thank you Susie